[Musique]
allez leur échappe allez vous le mettez
à mal si pour y arriver de la millière
la farigoule aller à la bastille est
quel est le plat qui à votre avis est le
plus typiquement provençal j'en ai vu un
paquet voilà ce dont on a fait appel à
dos à dos ils voyaient j'en ai huit là
je vais l'a préparée et j'y mettrai de
l'aïe
j'ai mis aujourd'hui thiam adobe avait
mijoté pendant trois heures d'ousmane
deux semaines et que des bons macarons
et la bouillabaisse
non mais ça souvent quelques les gains
du joueur passe à l'abri avec sa soupe
de quoi aussi tous les quinze jours
le plus souvent c'est la bel abbès la
sauce de poisson et l'aïoli non l'aïoli
oui on l'a vu combien de fois par mois
avec une fois par mois dont une fois par
mois
est ce que vous aimez vous monsieur
l'aïoli ou vous préférez les pieds et
paquets quel est le plan provincial
préféré l'aïoli c'est le cas potentiels
qui ont préféré des trois salles non
long de la moselle
alors quel est le plat provençal que
vous préférez justement pour quelqu'un
qui n'est pas de la provence c'est
intéressant à savoir 20 des tomates des
courgettes des vergers du père fois-là
la bohémienne enfin je n'aime pas trop
me refais un si beau si et la
bouillabaisse voulez mais oui mais je
n'ai pas à faire est ce que vous savez
faire les pieds et paquets non le gras
double oui vous l'aimez vous le faites
souvent n'ont pas tellement souvent mais
enfin quelquefois aimez vous faire
l'aïoli madame je sais pas le faire
tu vas d'ici
un permis et l'état et les sauva les
pieds paquets par exemple fait avec des
tripes avec des états d'aromates de
prévention qui sont formidables à mon
avis vous en faites souvent non pas très
souvent parce que c'est en place et l'on
a préparé ses très bons c'est excellent
les bolides avec le peigné laye sarr le
fait pas non ça sort le vide
avery mais qu'est-ce qui me tape dessus
le faisons pas ça ego bolide c'est pour
les petits qui naissent au sein de
l'équipe où tu sais comme le pen dessus
la balle est passée dans la panade ici
[Musique]